[Música]
un mes después de la explosión que
sacudió beirut equipos chilenos de
rescate realizan una operación junto a
las fuerzas de seguridad libanesas al
encontrar un posible signo de vida bajo
los escombros de un edificio colapsado
en el centro de la capital con un minuto
de silencio se honrará a las víctimas
tenemos reporte desde beirut
tras la visita de los dos candidatos
presidenciales a que no ya hay cruce de
acusaciones entre donald trump y joe
biden en medio de los casos de
brutalidad policial que estremecen a
eeuu que ha sacudido desde hace meses
por históricas protestas contra el
racismo y la violencia policial en
rochester fueron suspendidos siete
policías por la muerte de otro
afroamericano
el cine es uno de los rubros más
afectados en medio de la crisis de el
coronavirus y sus medidas de aislamiento
en la quinta entrega de informes sobre
la cultura en tiempos de la pandemia hoy
hablamos del reconocido cine mexicano
hola cómo están muy buenos días en
américa latina' ya todos ustedes que nos
siguen por la señal de france 24 mi
nombre es alan austria sean bienvenidos
empezamos en el líbano donde equipos
chilenos de rescate en beirut buscan
señales de vida bajo los escombros luego
de que tecnología detectar a ruidos bajo
un edificio colapsado cuyos escombros no
han sido removidos en un barrio en el
centro de la capital
la operación se registra un mes después
de la explosión que sacudió al país y
que dejó 190 muertos y más de 6.500
heridos hoy se conmemora a las víctimas
de la tragedia con un minuto de silencio
el periodista joan cabasés tiene más
detalles desde beirut
beirut cumple un mes tras la explosión y
lo hace con resignación ayer el ejército
libanés encontró en el puerto cuatro
toneladas más de nitrato de amonio la
sustancia exclusiva que supuestamente
provocó la tragedia del pasado 4 de
agosto el primer ministro en funciones
hasan diab ha sido interrogado en la
investigación por la explosión hasta
ahora ninguna de las 25 detenciones que
se han practicado ha tenido vinculación
con altos cargos a pesar de que varios
documentos demuestran que tenían
conocimiento de la presencia de los
explosivos en el puerto de beirut
mientras tanto el barrio de sema y se
lleva en vilo 24 horas a noche equipos
de rescate chilenos advirtieron de la
presencia de dos cuerpos bajo la runa a
uno de ellos supuestamente el de un niño
le detectaron posibles signos de vida
anuncian que sus dispositivos no son
100% fiables y que un milagro es
improbable pero aún así han estado toda
la noche siguiendo con los trabajos de
rescate ayer las autoridades locales
querían bloquear la búsqueda durante la
noche hasta el día siguiente pero la
presión popular les hizo cambiar de
opinión
nos vamos a eeuu donde el presidente de
donald trump atacó a su contrincante
demócrata joe biden asegurando que es
cómplice de vándalos de izquierda las
declaraciones se produjeron tras la
oleada de críticas que recibió trombo
luego de que biden viajará a que no sea
y se reuniera con los padres de jake
blake y hablará con el afroamericano por
teléfono y después enviará un mensaje de
unidad veamos más en este informe de
valentina datos h
una marioneta del socialismo así
calificó el presidente de donald trump a
su rival demócrata joe biden durante
todo el verano bayrén guardó silencio
mientras los vándalos de la extrema
izquierda atacaron brutalmente a las
fuerzas del orden en todas las ciudades
controladas por los demócratas
incendiaron negocios aterrorizaron a los
civiles
maiden nunca podrá proteger sus trabajos
ni a su familia es un títere de los
socialistas marxistas extremistas que
odian a los policías
las declaraciones del mandatario se
presentan luego de que bailen viajar a
wisconsin se reuniera con la familia del
joven afroamericano jake blake quien
quedó paralizado tras varios disparos de
un agente blanco y pidiera que se evite
la violencia
nada justifica los saqueos los incendios
o cualquier otra cosa por lo tanto
independientemente de lo enojado que
esté si alguien saqueado quema debe
rendir cuentas como alguien que hace
cualquier otra cosa punto el viaje de
bailén despertó una oleada de críticas
contra el mandatario que estuvo en la
ciudad de que no sea el martes pasado
pero no mencionó a blake y sólo mostró
su apoyo a los comercios afectados en
medio de las protestas contra el racismo
y la brutalidad policial impulsadas tras
lo ocurrido con blake en las últimas
semanas el mandatario se ha ponderado
como el único candidato capaz de
mantener la ley y el orden en el país
sin embargo su favorabilidad se
encuentra en jaque por la crisis del
cobi y el manejo de las protestas
precisamente este miércoles se conoció
un nuevo caso washington en el que un
policía le disparó a un afroamericano de
18 años quitándole la vida asimismo se
hizo público el caso de daniel frit un
hombre afro de 41 años que falleció
después de que
de la policía de rochester lo detuvieron
y le presionarán la cabeza contra el
pavimento los hechos ocurrieron en marzo
pasado
y sobre el caso de bruce con el que
cierre el informe y quien falleció
después de que agentes lo detuvieran y
le presionarán la cabeza contra el
pavimento se confirmó la noticia de que
siete policías de rochester fueron
suspendidos por nosotros noticias y es
que el consejo del atlántico norte el
máximo órgano de la toma de decisiones
de la otan condenó el ataque contra el
opositor ruso alexéi navalni y pidió
llevar ante la justicia a los
responsables del hecho por su parte la
unión europea pidió a moscú que
investigue su envenenamiento y no
descarta sanciones rusia asegura que no
hay evidencia de un crimen contra el
activista y hasta ahora no ha abierto
una investigación criminal sobre este
caso vamos a este informe de aurora
bayod
acusaban a las autoridades rusas de no
actuar pero este viernes un tribunal
rechazó una denuncia presentada por los
aliados del crítico del kremlin alexéi
navalni en esta acusaban a un alto
organismo de aplicación de la ley de
inacción sobre lo que dijeron que era un
intento de asesinato ni aprobó ninguna
decisión sobre la apertura de un caso
criminal u otra decisión tomada por el
comité de investigación de acuerdo con
el código de procedimiento penal
un día antes la unión europea instó al
gobierno ruso a llevar a cabo una
investigación exhaustiva y transparente
del caso nabhani y por primera vez se
refirió a posibles sanciones
el uso de armas químicas en cualquier
circunstancia es completamente
inaceptable y una violación del derecho
internacional de la unión europea fue
muy clara en su firme condena del uso de
este agente químico contra el señor
naval
mista naval en respuesta el kremlin
rechazó cualquier sugerencia de que
rusia hubiera estado detrás del ataque y
dijo que no veía motivos para imponer
sanciones amos
contestando
no creo que pueda ser beneficioso para
alguien si se piensa bien no queremos
que nuestros socios en alemania y en
otros países europeos se precipiten en
estimaciones preferiríamos estar en
diálogo
estas declaraciones llegaron un día
después de que la cancillera alemana
angela merkel dijera que al oponente
ruso había sido envenenado por un agente
de tipo no bychkov este caso también
podría tener graves consecuencias para
el proyecto de gasoducto nord stream 2
que se esperaba suministrará gas ruso a
europa ya alemania en particular
un nuevo análisis de amnistía
internacional encontró que al menos
siete mil personas trabajadoras de la
salud han muerto en todo el mundo
después de contraer kobe 19 en américa
el continente más afectado por la
pandemia méxico lidera la trágica lista
con al menos 1300 20 fallecimientos en
eeuu la nación con mayor número de
contagios y decesos por kobe 19 las
cifras alcanzan los 1.077 sanitarios
fallecidos seguido de brasil el
epicentro de la enfermedad en américa
latina' con 634 mientras que la
organización alarma de la rápida
propagación de la enfermedad entre el
personal sanitario sigue el pedido por
más garantías de protección y seguridad
sanitaria para ellos álvaro cordero nos
habla de esta situación en mexico
los profesionales de la salud mexicanos
son los más afectados por la pandemia de
coronavirus hasta 1.320 trabajadores han
perdido la vida en su lucha contra el
virus de los más de 97 mil 600
contagiados estos son los datos más
altos del mundo que superan a los de
países como eeuu o brasil en méxico el
número oficial de muertes de personas
trabajadoras de la salud ha llegado a
las cifras sobrecogedora de 1.320
personas el 25 de agosto el ministerio
de salud de méxico confirmó 97 mil 632
casos de kobe 19 entre las personas
trabajadoras de la salud la causa los
constantes brotes en centros médicos
registrados por la falta de equipos
protectores incluso media después del
primer caso registrado esto se siente
especialmente en las provincias pero
estos no son los únicos datos negativos
que registra el país su tasa de
mortalidad con respecto a los contagios
es con diferencia la más alta del mundo
con 10,8 por ciento prácticamente dobla
a las cifras de otros países como irán
perú bolivia o indonesia algo que desde
el gobierno justifican con la condición
física de los mexicanos pero
se puede deber a la falta de pruebas lo
que los datos nos dicen hasta el momento
y no solo los datos en méjico es que las
principales comorbilidades que generan
enfermedad grave y por lo tanto
defunciones en kobe de 19 al menos son
estos 3 sobrepeso y obesidad diabetes e
hipertensión y eso es algo que es una
prevalencia alta en la población
mexicana y por lo tanto también
contribuye definitivamente los
resultados que hemos visto a pesar de
los datos méxico está en pleno
desconocimiento desde hace meses un
movimiento que busca reactivar la
maltrecha economía pero que según las
cifras ha acelerado la pandemia
vamos a europa y es que tres días
después de su reapertura cierran las
escuelas en francia debido al
coronavirus el ministro francés de
educación dijo que 22 escuelas de su
territorio se vieron obligadas a
cancelar las clases por los casos del
cob y 19 más de 12 millones de
estudiantes volvieron a los centros
educativos el martes entre críticas por
parte de sindicatos de padres y
profesores y es que el país experimenta
un fuerte repunte de contagios con más
de 7000 en 24 horas durante los últimos
dos días
seguimos en este continente y es que el
ex presidente del gobierno italiano
silvio berlusconi ha sido ingresado en
el hospital san raffaele de milán este
viernes después de dar positivo por
corona virus y padecer una neumonía
bilateral el cuadro clínico no es
preocupante explicaron sus portavoces el
empresario y ex mandatario aseguró ayer
que se encontraba bien y que continuaba
trabajando sin embargo si pidió a través
de twitter que son necesarias medidas
más rigurosas en este país para asegurar
la salud pública en medio de la pandemia
[Música]
y en la quinta entrega de informes sobre
cultura en medio de la pandemia vamos
ahora a méjico es que la industria
cinematográfica del país una de las
naciones más importantes en la escena
fílmica padece los estragos de la crisis
derivada por la pandemia y salir a flote
ha sido un camino cuesta arriba desde la
producción hasta la exhibición con un
público escéptico aún ante la seguridad
sanitaria en la nueva normalidad vamos a
este informe de nuestro corresponsal
mario carbonell en méxico país que junto
a argentina es el de mayor producción
fílmica de latinoamérica la pandemia
deja un sector extenuado tras más de
cuatro meses de cierre obligado de salas
la cámara nacional de la industria
cinematográfica estima que se han dejado
de vender 152 millones de boletos lo que
equivale a una pérdida de más de 330
millones de dólares para poder reabrir
los cines han tenido que aplicar
estrictos protocolos de higiene y
reducir su aforo nuestras salas están
adaptadas a una capacidad del 30 por
ciento del aforo total del complejo
aplicar estas medidas sanitarias ha
tenido un alto costo todos los insumos y
los parados no se están encareciendo la
propia operación y nos tuvimos que
financiar para poder eso para poder
llevar esto y para poder abrir y para
volver a filmar las casas productoras
también debieron pagar el costo de los
protocolos sanitarios sumado a las
pérdidas que ya tenían tras un rodaje
detenido más de cuatro meses la cineasta
paula astorga tuvo que cambiar el set
del trigal el filme que actualmente
produce ahí perdimos mucho dinero porque
había cosas que se habían paquete a
bodega moss y que en el momento de
regresar a filmar que ya no tenemos las
condiciones porque él no hay aeropuertos
para regresar a filmar tan lejos tuvimos
que cambiar a una locación aquí en el
estado de puebla además del embate del
cob y de la industria cinematográfica
enfrenta la amenaza de perder los apoyos
gubernamentales producto de la autoridad
aplicada en la administración de andrés
manuel lópez obrador la idea generó una
inconformidad liderada por figuras como
el director guillermo del toro y el
actor gael garcía que han buscado
convencer al congreso de la importancia
de mantener los fondos
digitales de apoyo no serían muy
competitivos en un mercado que está
dañado por la falta de protección
primigenia que sucedió en el tratado de
libre comercio
queremos que el apoyo principal de estos
fondos creo es para los nuevos
realizadores de todo las partes de
mexico para la gente menos favorecida la
iniciativa se frenó pero la intención
persiste y mientras la industria del
cine lucha por sobrevivir resurge en
algunas tradiciones que se adaptan a las
circunstancias como los autocinemas así
las audiencias también se han tenido que
ajustar a los nuevos tiempos y mire
finalizamos con información deportiva y
es que el futuro del delantero de
argentina lionel messi en el barcelona
sigue siendo una incógnita a pesar de
que se informan noticias diferentes
sobre su estadía en este club jorge
messi y su padre y representante que
llegó este miércoles a españa para
reunirse con el presidente azulgrana
acudió también este viernes a sus
oficinas en la capital catalana para
reunirse con los abogados que están
llevando el caso
lionel messi
seguiremos pendientes del caso del
delantero de argentina y del club
barcelona muchas gracias por su compañía
llegamos al final pero los invitamos a
que sigan con nosotros ya que se cuiden
cuídense mucho del cobi 19
[Música]